i heard jesse jackson speak when i was a  kid saying that uh excellence is the  best deterrent to racism excellence is  the best deterrent to sexism and so i  went home and i put that on my mirror  and that really became my motto so eight  i was one of those kids that made all  the kids sick because i was the first  one to turn in the book report and i was  the you know read the most books and i  would say reading  is the strongest  signal for success in the future that  i've ever seen it is the strongest  strongest strongest i got my first job  in radio  uh when i was 16 years old because i've  been broadcasting since i was 16 years  old but my first job i got because i was  a great reader when you are a great  reader you can articulate and speak  and command the english language in ways  that other people cannot and people  think you're a lot smarter than you are  lots of times because you're a great  reader i would say it's the absolute  greatest foundation